you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between Bobby Fischer playing on the
white end and Oscar Pan Oh this is from
the way no Saturday's tournament of 1970
Fischer is still a couple years away
from becoming world champion and well
how to describe this one reminded of one
of Fischer's quotes tactics flow from a
superior position well let's see how
this superior position comes about
Fischer kicks off with E for the
Argentine Grandmaster replying with the
Sicilian defense but this quickly
transposes into Kings Indian attack land
white is paying some special attention
to deploying the King side first
meanwhile black is staying fluid with
the pawn structure the D pawn in
particular has yet to commit and the
bishops eyes remain open only after Rick
to e1 do we have black taking a step to
prevent white from establishing a pawn
on e5
if white can establish a pawn on e5 that
guy will often act as a great catalyst
for a King side attack so black says not
so fast
see three this is already an important
moment in the game blacks reply is to
Castle another move to strongly consider
here is e five and this addresses
White's plan of expanding in the center
that prevents ePHI prevents deform so
after castles I mean one take on that
move is to say okay the king is tucked
away King safe the ready to play I think
a better take on that better way to view
blacks last move is black saying I'm
okay
if white establishes a Pandu on the
center
or I'm okay if white establishes a space
advantage why is this the case why can
we kind of view it like this well what
do we have we have an ideal pond center
and what is black - now do to challenge
it one way to approach it is maybe Queen
to b6 that could turn into a very sharp
variation striking at it from the side
not yet challenging the duo with one of
blacks pawns but in the game we have the
move d5 that's how black looks to
challenge White's ideal pawn center
Fischer follows up with E 5 and has now
established this great strength on e5
the central structure after just these
11 moves is one that goes unchanged for
the rest of the game and if there's one
square that pops out in this position
more than any other to me it's the
square f6 it's a hole and it's
controlled by one of whites pawns d6
also falls in under that definition but
it's really the f6 square because it's
closer to the black King and also you'll
see plenty of games where there can be
many different white pieces when placed
on f6 they will support some type of
mating attack you could see a knight
there a bishop there a pond there a
queen there basically anything but a
rook or a king I guess but yeah that f6
square is really critical is the short
story following up we have Bishop d7
we do have one open file so both sides
will be putting their queen rooks there
Knight c3 of course is there better
square for him no ripped to c8 Bishop to
f4 so if black wanted to challenge the
pawn on e5 the the best time to do that
would have been right after white played
pawn to e5 the computer even suggests
you could do that in other at other
points down the line but really the
first opportunity given to strike at the
pawn on e5 black should have done that
on move 11
we don't have that though Knight to a5
rook c1 and now B for so following up we
have b3 this is just taking away squares
nothing nothing more light doesn't want
to see the night arrived on Cu form I
move like b3 you'll have to maybe think
twice about as white in position types
where the bishop is not being ketab
otherwise you may end up losing control
over the C file if you can't operate on
that c1 square you could have some
difficulties not the case here b4 Knight
to e2 Bishop b5 Queen to d2 so it's it's
flowing very in a very logical way what
Fischer is doing here just
connecting rooks with this last one as
well as forming a battery so this is
another idea that white has in mind to
exchange dark square bishop switch would
do what we can blacks kingside which
would make the likelihood of a piece one
day arriving on f6 that much more
powerful continuing rook - you are
assuming Knight to c6 and now G form so
this is this was an interesting moment
because one might think well let's go in
for rook to c5 he can't be challenged on
that Square immediately and we're gonna
prepare to double but that type of play
will quickly be neutralized what will
likely happen are both Brooks being
exchanged white has a different idea in
mind with g4 my initial thought with the
g4 move was okay it's taking away the
square from the knight but can you spot
the other idea it's an important one in
another big decision right here for team
black the game move is a5 and you know
this is looking for a four but at the
same time it's saying you know what I am
valuing my bishop more than your knight
is extremely important an important
moment to consider because g4 is also
opening up the g3 square for the night
and that's what we have night to g3 so
this bishop
is he more valuable than the night
that's a that's a question black had to
really weigh at that moment as it stands
right now and what we're going to
observe in the game is that the bishop
is kind of staring off into space
there's no other black piece that can
coordinate well with that bishop it
would be a much different story if one
of the Black Knights can somehow let's
say make use of the d3 square the bishop
would be there to support it it's just
not the case here
and so what black should have done at
this moment instead of a5 is to snap off
the night on e2 before he gets to g3 yet
another one of whites pieces is now
drifting towards the Kings side all
minor pieces and soon we're gonna have
the G and H pawns and let's not forget
about the Queen there's a lot of energy
that is being built up over here on the
Kings side
continuing Queen to b6 here comes h4
Knight to b8 this is a best move by
black there are too many different moves
to really choose from 414 black this
Knight is actually prepared to one day
defend against h7 in this way he's
headed for the f8 square so continuing
we have Bishop h6 good form multiple
reasons
get rid of the bad bishop four good
bishop and yeah let's get rid of this
key defender this master defender Knight
d7 Queen g5 one rook is off Bishop takes
Queen takes another rook is off and now
we have h5 & move number 26 is a game
losing move here for team black Queen to
d8 it would have been better if black
plays Knight to f8 straight away one of
the main differences here between Queen
to d8 and Knight to f8 is that when the
Queen is on da she no longer has
pressure on d4 this is now one less
thing white has to worry about this
Knight is now much more free to move he
can now jump in to the g5 square and
that's exactly what happens
Knight g5 Knight to FA and white has as
I said right in the beginning of the
video that quote by fischer tactics flow
from a superior position this is without
question a superior position for white
once more this Bishop not doing a whole
lot this Knight is kind of yeah what's
he up to
nobody knows one pop quiz for this game
right here this moment move 28
what would you do in this position if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what you can come up with what was
Fisher's move
okay one move is to go ahead and smash
away on h7 but the best is the gay move
Bishop to e4
a star move of the game for sure likely
a move that Oscar did not see coming and
[Music]
what is the drawback if pawn takes
Bishop that wasn't played in the game
let's have a look at what would happen
pawn takes Bishop in comes the night on
g3 and where's he headed the f6 square
supported by that pawn and there's no
good defense against this what do you do
this isn't even a defense but just to
highlight he's in there with great
effect
that's check King here and Knight G
takes h7 it's already reading a million
- there's no good defense from here the
Knights ready to move and discover check
etc
so yeah that's a super poison right
there on e4 can't take him Queen to e7
is tempted providing some lateral
defense once this capture occurs on g6
Knight takes h7 is the follow-up
beautiful sacrifice Knight takes H takes
G F takes and Bishop takes so two pawns
are picked up White has given up a minor
piece for those two pawns and there
really isn't anything good for black
here the idea is you know there is not
just one route to the f6 square now that
there is no g6 pawn around let's not
forget the knight can also pivot on h5
and then sweep into the f6 square so
that's right here by the way just to
highlight let's say if black tries
something like Queen to g7 at this
moment the knight can be captured
oh I can pick up another pond and that
night will fall next so what does black
do at this point
Knight g5 Knight h5 heading for the f6
square and Fisher has calculated this
one out to its end after Knight to f3 he
sees that his King could simply walk all
the way up and he can afford to no
longer have the bishop in on the attack
the Queen in Knight combo they are just
too great Knight f6 follows King to f7
and after Queen to h7 black resigns
there's only one move King to f8 would
be met with Queen to g8
a really smooth game I don't know that's
the impression I got from this one it
just seemed really it just seemed to
flow very logical throughout feel free
to share what your thoughts are on this
one
I enjoyed covering this one and
hopefully enjoyed watching this game
against Oscar Pan Oh as usual feel free
to leave any feedback in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next video
that's all for now take care bye
you